Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Marvel is
going to be airing a super special first look
at footage from Avengers 2 Age of Ultron next
week, so for my Marvel Movie video today I
wanted to talk a little about what we’ve
learned about the story so far and how it
informs where all the phase 3 movies are going.
I will be posting a breakdown of that Age
of Ultron footage as soon as it posts next
Tuesday too, so be sure to subscribe to get
it if you’re finding me for the first time.
It’s going to be amazing.
So first here’s some specific details about
the new footage.
It’s going to air on ABC Tuesday March 18th
at 8PM Eastern Time during a special called
Marvel: Assembling A Universe.
It’s a special they’re airing instead
of a new episode of Agents of SHIELD.
It’s meant to be a deep look into the Marvel
Universe that integrates all of the movies
and TV Shows (remember that there will be
a few new TV Shows coming).
Integrates everything so that they can tell
one large story across multiple movies and
shows.
There will be new footage from Avengers Age
of Ultron, Captain America The Winter Soldier
and Guardians of The Galaxy.
I’ll talk about everything, but mostly my
breakdown will focus on Age of Ultron, since
this will be the first official footage we’ve
seen.
There have been a few pictures and clips of
them filming the movie, but they’re really
low quality.
Right now the only real footage of the movie
we’ve seen was the origin Comic Con announcement
trailer.
Which was really only an image of Ultron.
Since then we’ve learned who most of the
new characters will be including Vision voiced
by Paul Bettany, who also does the voice of
JARVIS.
There will probably be a motion capture element
to his performance as well as James Spader
who is voicing Ultron.
Then there’s the other two major additions,
Quicksilver played by Aaron Johnson and Scarlet
Witch played by Elizabeth Olsen.
Even if they aren’t featured in the video
next Tuesday, they are rumored to be in one
of the Captain America Winter Soldier Post
Credits Scenes.
So we will get to see what they look like
and what their powers look like on screen.
Isn’t it funny that X-Men Days of Future
Past features Quicksilver in a major role,
but we’re seeing the character for the first
time at the end of a totally different movie.
I wonder how Bryan Singer and FOX feel about
that?
Thematically Age of Ultron is like the beginning
of a new age for Super Heroes and Super Villains
in the Marvel Universe.
Think of it as The Age of Miracles, I would
call it the Age of Mutants.
But since FOX legally has the rights to the
X-Men Franchise, only they get to use the
term “Mutant” in their movies.
So Marvel is substituting the term “Miracles”
to broadly imply that Magic and other strange
abilities are going to play a huge role going
forward.
It’s all just paving the way to The Infinity
Gauntlet.
A recent early review of Captain America Winter
Soldier included some spoilers for two separate
Post-Credits scenes.
Turn the volume down now if you don’t want
to know anything about it.
So one of them was just a Winter Soldier specific
scene.
But the other Post Credits clip was for Avengers
Age of Ultron.
It also features Baron Von Strucker.
He’s keeping them locked in an underground
cell and it’s just a quick shot of Quicksilver
bouncing around the walls at super speed and
Scarlet Witch levitating objects in the air.
Strucker has the only dialogue and says The
Age of Miracle is upon us.
Okay you can turn the volume back up now.
Spoilers over.
So let’s talk a little about Phase 3, because
Age of Ultron is the last movie before Ant
Man, the official beginning of that next phase
of movies.
Kevin Feige was quoted a couple years ago
as saying in the broad sense that Phase 3
represented Magic.
Opening the door to all the Doctor Strange
rumors you may have been hearing recently.
That movie hasn’t officially been announced,
but Marvel still has two untitled movies scheduled
for phase 3 in addition to Ant Man, Thor 3,
Captain America 3 and Avengers 3.
In keeping with the theme of Magic, Doctor
Strange would be the logical choice for one
of those movies.
There’s also the possibility of a female
driven movie like Black Widow.
Marvel has said they’ve got more than one
in development, but nothing has been officially
announced.
Unofficially the rumor is that Ms Marvel is
the other film in development.
Black Panther is another possibility for that
other untitled film.
So now let’s talk a little about the plot
of Age of Ultron.
We know a few details based on comments Joss
Whedon has made and behind the scenes images.
After the initial Comic Con announcement last
year Whedon talked about the evolution of
Ultron during the movie.
They are going to change his appearance, so
in his final version he won’t look like
the Comic Book version.
The origin of the character is different too.
I haven’t done an Ant Man video yet, but
Hank Pym in the movie won’t be his creator
like in the Comics.
In Age of Ultron he’s going to evolve from
a Military AI version of JARVIS, so essentially
Tony Stark will be his father.
Whedon just said that they were doing it this
way because they wanted Ultron to flow from
things that they had already developed.
And they’ve been developing the Tony Stark
character since 2008.
On paper he shares a lot of similarities with
Hank Pym.
But if you’ve read the comics, especially
recently with Marvel’s Avengers A.I.
series.
Hank Pym seems like he’s way more unstable
than Tony Stark.
But since Stark Tech will give birth to Ultron,
you can understand why the voice of JARVIS,
Paul Bettany, is the logical choice to play
The Vision.
He’s an android that’s created by Ultron
to help him defeat the Avengers.
So it will be Tony Stark giving birth to Ultron
giving birth to The Vision.
So get excited, like Baron Von Strucker said,
this will be the Age of Miracles.
So now that I’ve dropped all that info on
you let me know what you’re most excited
to see in the movie.
Ultron?
Vision?
all the new powers from Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch?
Like I said, I’ll be posting a full breakdown
of the footage next Tuesday night when it
airs, be sure to subscribe to get it.
In the meantime be sure to let me know which
Marvel movie you want me to do a video for
next.
Right now click here to learn about my Ms
Marvel Agents of SHIELD theories and click
here for my Top Picks for The Doctor Strange
Movie.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!